I'm Casey neistat and this is the wired
autocomplete
[Music]
interview ah well I mean I'm a little
nervous whenever I Google my own name it
gets a little sketch but um I'm here for
it and I am
ready okay what made Casey neistat
famous probably it's like my striking
good looks I think is what put me out
there in front you know if not that
maybe the early Al films that my brother
van and I made 2003 3 years before
YouTube was the first time we had a
movie that like went super viral is this
all one take yes sir what did Casey you
should have one that says does Casey
nice that bite his fingernails cuz the
answer to that is a strong yes what did
Casey and IAT do before YouTube so I've
really only ever had two professional
like Endeavors in my life one is being
like a filmmaker YouTuber or whatever
and the other one is being a
professional dishwasher I worked in in
like a a kind of a dumpy seafood
restaurant in New England and I would
like scrub chowder pots and pots and
pans and I I'm still a good dishwasher I
just don't do it professionally what
camera Casey neistat uses whatever I
have in my hand my favorite camera right
now is like the Sony A7 S3 I think it's
just easy and it looks super pro but
also it's like whatever cell phone I'm
using at the time is a camera that I'll
use GoPro is like Rock Solid insta 360
lets me do like tricks and people think
I have like a crew with me but it's just
like a little $200 camera whatever's
that arms length is my favorite camera
in that moment what sunglasses this
Casey ice that we okay I always wear the
same sunglasses this isn't necessarily
an endorsement I mean unless Rayban you
want to you can call me but they are
Rayband folding Wayfair so they like
fold and I find the folding ones wrap
around your head better I've got a huge
head so they stay on better but then
like the paint and all that is that's
more for me not rayen what app did Casey
and IEP make in
2015 my partner Matt hacket and I
launched a social app called beam BME
and beam was like kind of like a
predecessor or a rougher version of like
Snapchat stories and unfortunately
Snapchat stories is just better we did
really well with the app but we never
had like the broad appeal of Snapchat
but starting that company making that
app was one of like the greatest
Endeavors of my life I love doing it how
does
K how
does how
does who's got fingernails are a
Sharpie how does Casey net fly drones in
New York City okay flying a drone in New
York city is against the
law
but but somebody told me that and that's
how I fly drones you'll always notice my
New York City Drone footage is like
garbage cuz it's like a little baby
drone how much does Casey ni that sleep
short answer is as much as possible but
usually that's like 5 hours 6 hours a
night I hate sleep sleep the wind and
cobblestones those are my enemies in
life I respect them I fear them but what
a pain in the ass how did Casey and IAT
meet Candace pool it's my wife we were
both invited to a bar mitzvah in Houston
Texas and we kind of like knew each
other in New York and I remember she
called me and she's like hey I'm from
Houston if you need a place to stay you
can stay at my parents house and I was
like excellent they like gave me a like
the guest room at her parents house and
I just you know did everything I could
to try to sneak into Candace's room
didn't work out but that's that's how
things got started how does Casey IAT
make money I never made money until I
started really would like YouTube you
know I was like a teenager I was on
welfare I had no money and then it
wasn't like a straight line up into the
right of making money it was like one of
these and like sometimes it be all the
way down there like when I started my
tech company in 2015 I was like hundreds
of thousands of dollars in debt and I
couldn't could afford to pay Candace
pool my wife my share of the rent she'd
have to cover for me so I was like in
debt then and then I started YouTube and
I sold my tech company and like did
stuff like that and I started to make
money then so like it's it's complicated
that's fine right what a question okay
where's Casey niat from you think they
mean like where was I born or like they
want to know the history of the neistat
lineage origin story the whole origin
story Nana was from Yonkers New York and
then moved to Southeastern Connecticut
after the war in the 40s and 50s and
that's where my like Dad was born and
then that's where I was raised so like
Southeastern Connecticut Connecticut's
like a fancy State and most people you
meet in New York City when they say I'm
from Connecticut they're from like the
like Greenwich like the rich part I was
from like literally the other side of
the tracks grot in Connecticut like a
military-industrial town when Reagan
left office and Clinton Clinton was
after Reagan right Clinton came in
nobody knows no one in here Clinton came
in like all my friends parents lost
their job at the submarine base cuz
military expenditures were like that's
what I remember from my childhood I
moved to New York City when I was 18 or
19 or something like that where did case
I that go to school mostly in
Southeastern Connecticut I went to jil's
fairy elementary school I went to
ledgard Junior High School I went to
ledard high school until freshman year
and then I ran away from home and moved
to Williamsburg Virginia my brother van
was at William and Mary he adopted me so
I could go to high school in Virginia
where I went to God I wish I remember
the name it was like something Town
Jamestown high school or something for
one year and then that was it sophomore
year I think was the last year of high
school that I I completed where does
Casey IAT run wherever I am the New York
City marathon is exactly 3 weeks from
right now I used to run a lot of
marathons I think this will be like my
24th or 25th Marathon now I run one
Marathon a year which is New York City I
will never miss it's my favorite day in
New York and I'm running this year for a
fantastic nonprofit called Project
Healthy Minds which you know know tries
to destigmatize mental health issues and
it's something close to home for me but
the New York City marathon is just the
greatest day of the year in New York
whether you're a spectator or a runner
but as a runner it's like you and 60,000
other people being celebrated all day
long and celebrating the city where's
Casey IAT Studio my studio is in
Chinatown in New York City Tribeca is
the neighborhood next to Chinatown
that's like fancy sometimes I'll say
Chinatown because it's right on the
border and Chinatown is the truth but
then if I want it to sound fancier I'll
say trica but the truth is I'm like
right on the edge of yeah it's a great
spot all right holy smokes when is snack
does Casey ni to edit his own videos I
edit all my own stuff a thousand videos
on my YouTube channel and I would say
every single one of them with the
exception of of a couple literally like
two maybe three I edited completely
myself the other two or three that I
didn't I made with my friend Max who's a
better editor than me and he and I would
like sit together and cut it together
but yeah I edit everything myself mostly
cuz like I don't know what the story is
the video is I do the writing in the
edit I don't know what the video is I
have an idea but it's in the edit that I
find the story a friend of mine works
for Mr Beast and I've been on a couple
of Mr Beast shoots we went to South
Africa together a year ago and that guy
for a YouTuber runs the level of
production that's like much closer to
Hollywood he's got teams of people it's
super like efficiently run he's got
professionals everywhere and it's
overwhelming it's incredible the way he
does it so if there's like a Mr Beast
level production here on the other end
the first this other end of that
spectrum is the way I do it I don't even
have like an office helper I have no one
so I do everything when it comes like
mopping the floors and take out my trash
bags at the end of the day to holding
the camera doing all the cinematography
doing all the writing doing all the
editing changing lenses every aspect of
the production I do myself and I love it
like it's my favorite part is the doing
when I see these big sets like 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 n there are nine people in this
room to make this video right now you're
very lovely people but it's like a it's
a lot of management it's a lot of
thinking I just want to be like that
painter in his Studio painting the
canvas by himself I just don't know how
to paint so I use cameras and my like
MacBook did case I said climb Mount
Everest no I didn't climb Mount Everest
In fairness there is like a really epic
thumbnail of Me on YouTube from when I
climbed a mountain called aen kaga which
is the highest mountain in the southern
hemisphere 23,000 ft I think and I
climbed that and I had this like plan
when I was younger to climb all the
Seven Summits like the seven highest
peaks on all seven continents I did
Africa kilman J piece of cake you should
do that and then number two was Aken
kagwa and after we got to the top of the
mountain I was like this like I'm
done like I did two of the Seven Summits
but no I did not climb Mount Everest and
I never will does Casey and IAT own 368
368 is a company that I started in
2019 with a fantastic guy named Paul a
368 is a a collaborative
production event space in downtown New
York City and 368 is very much still
alive and operating all the time I don't
own it and I don't run it when I moved
out of New York City to Los Angeles to
be closer to family in 2020 I kind of
gave Paul the keys to 368 and he has
been realizing that Vision ever since so
I still I was in there yesterday I see
it every day talk to Paul all the time I
love what 368 is doing but like you know
again I'm just alone in my office is
taking out the garbage and mopping the
floors I feel like I'm finding the
Rhythm Casey ice at electric skateboard
is that a question I got a present in
the mail I want to say 2015 I don't know
it's on camera but it was a boosted
board which is a name brand of an
electric skateboard I fell in love it's
the greatest thing ever and since
getting that like I no longer ride bikes
in New York City I don't take the subway
in New York City I don't take taxis or
Ubers in New York City the only way I
get around is on a boosted board now
regrettably boost boed board the company
went out of business in like 2018 or
2019 sanj the founder it was not his
fault these guys came in they're like we
got to make the company bigger let's
make a scooter nobody wants a scooter
and they tanked the company so I bought
like 20 of them and I still ride boosted
boards so yes if that was a question yes
Casey IAT electric skateboard Casey I
YouTube stats I looked at my YouTube app
yesterday and I have lost 6,000
subscribers this month so I think I have
like 12 and half million subscribers and
no joke every time I post a video
there's like this subtle like I posted a
video about like when New York City got
flooded a week and a half ago that gave
me like 20,000 new subscribers then
sometimes I'll post videos about like my
kids or something I'll lose subscribers
not nice World up until my first I think
170 million views took 170 million views
for me to get to I think around 300,000
subscribers and that was like 7 years
and then I started my daily Vlog like a
daily show on YouTube I posted a video
every single day um that was like kind
of consistent so it's like an episodic
so 7 years to get to 300,000 subscribers
12 months to get to 10 million
subscribers maybe it was 18 months
something but it was insane that kind of
growth and I think that speaks to like
one flattered it meant people liked my
videos for sure but I also think like to
get to a place where you're actually
people want to subscribe like I would
like to see more videos from this
Channel people like to know what they're
getting and I think that that was the
first time did anything with real
consistency and it's like oh here's a
channel that uploads every day and I
like this kind of stuff I would like to
see more of that and now like I don't
know I'll go 3 months that uploading if
I get distracted so like when you click
subscribe right now I have no idea
what's going to be on the other side of
that and I think it's a much less
enticing offer if subscribership is a
goal of aspiring creators it's like you
got to be consistent and constant casy
iat's first video my first like real
video that I think people know about is
a video called iPod's dirty secret which
I made in 200 13 with my big brother van
and it was about how like the first
iPods Apple wouldn't replace the battery
in them so when like this $300 iPod died
you had to go buy a new iPod I was
really pissed cling me money so I was
like van let's make a video about this
and we made this funny video where we
put like cigarette warning labels all
over the iPod advertisements all around
New York City when I think of like what
was the first real video that kind of
started the whole 20-year trajectory
that was the video he nice that bike
Lanes I guess that I could have said too
bike Lanes was like the first video on
my YouTube channel now that really
popped off so like before YouTube you
know I was like doing commercial
Direction and I had a show on HBO that
my brother van and I wrote and directed
and edited and we did all kinds of stuff
in the movie world but like you know
YouTube didn't come out till 2006 and
then 2008 or 9 is when I started my
channel and I made a video called bike
lane shortly thereafter where I got a
ticket from an NYPD like a cop for
riding my bike like outside of the bike
lane which is preposterous if you're
been in New York City there's no way to
stay in the bike Lanes so I made this
video that just showed you can't ride in
the bike Lanes cuz you'll crash into
stuff I Illustrated that by crashing
into everything I found in the bike
lanes that video went crazy that video
did like millions of views and brought
all kinds of attention to my channel
that video you know maybe more than
anything else on my YouTube channel
really motivated me to like a I should
be taking posting videos online more
seriously Casey nice that equipment I
don't romanticize the equipment in fact
I find like when I meet photographers
ERS cinematographers filmmakers and they
want to talk about the gear it's like
talking to John Mayer about what guitar
he likes to use I want to know about
your music like how do you come up with
those sounds like how do you come up
with your lyrics like how do you do what
you do so like when people want to talk
about gear I I I kind of I think it's
like an insult it's like when you say
somebody's nice it's the worst thing you
can say about them CU it means you have
nothing interesting to say about that
person you just say they're nice do we
have more of these
or this the last one I mean we can bust
out the computer and just keep going I
have so many more answers case night
that marathon time am I supposed to
start up top is it going to screw up the
whole video you want me to like go in
reverse let's go in reverse I'm giving
the whole story how much film do you
have in these cameras it's digital they
can roll forever in 2006 something like
that I got in a motorcycle accident this
whole leg had to be rebuilt out of metal
so from my knee to my hip and my hip 8
in in is all titanium my orthopedist
said to me you'll never run again and
he's like you might be able to chase
after your kids but you're never going
to be a runner again and since then I've
run you know 24 25 marathons with a
single goal and that single goal was to
break 3 hours and 3 hours is like if you
watch like the fast guys the winners
three hours as slow as can be but for
like a novice 3 hours is like a real
Benchmark it means you're running a 6
minute and 54 Second Mile 26 times in a
row that is like the goal for me and in
15 years in 24 marathons I've never done
it but I have run a
301 this close Casey and Ice that knee
injury hey I kind of addressed that
really wo that one in it's a femur
injury my knees now are also messed up
because of this injury I compensate
because it's all metal over here that
messes up my knees but like the legs are
fine I did 9 miles this morning did 18
yesterday I'm good he's ni that airplane
I know what they're getting at here
flying first class was like something
that was like the thing that you like
walk through and try not to make eye
contact because it's like this dream
that I could never imagine like if a k
ticket cost 600 bucks in what world are
you going to spend two grand to sit in a
slightly better seat it was an
unimaginable thing okay then I had to
fly to Australia for work and I was
flying for Google Google's got the uh
you know what I'm talking about see how
it says YouTube right there yeah they're
getting paid for this they flew me
business class which is nothing to shake
a stick at and I was so blown away about
the business class that I made a video
flying to Australia about how awesome
business class was the airlin saw that
video while I was in Australia on my way
back to New York from Sydney I'm in the
airport and like somebody comes up to me
from the airline and they're like huh Mr
niist Hat and I was like busted for
something and instead they were like
we've upgraded you to first class and I
got to like sit in first class with like
a lay flat bed and like a door and all
this stuff but I had my backpack with
all my camera Gear with me so I produced
this like highly produced video of what
it was like to experience first class I
posted that video on YouTube and that
video has done more views than any video
I've ever made I think it's like 60
million views or something outrageous
and like got all this News Press cuz
nobody ever really like made that thing
kind of video before now there's like
10,000 of those videos they're all
interesting but there was a shower on
the plane you're in the sky and you're
showering there's a little light it goes
green yellow red and you got to get all
that that soap off before it hits red
otherwise it can be a very sticky flight
home he's and Ice Set n tuck it in
2007 or six or something like that my
brother van and I met a guy who started
a juice brand called the Tucket Nectars
his name is Tom and he went on to like
produce our HBO show and then Tom and I
were partners because of that I got to
like go to Nantucket which was a place
that was like a home for him and we
premiered a video might even been our
HBO series at the net Film Festival so
we always had this relationship with n
Tucket which is like this little tiny
island off the coast of Massachusetts I
always loved it there my family and I
vacation there it's a really special
place like I'd rather be there than
anywhere in the world except for New
York City it's my second favorite place
in the world okay does this mean this is
the last question you know what I could
do no it doesn't work
okay this is a terrible uninteresting
question to end on we can Sharpie a
final question here vog music I have
like people all around the world that
that email me or DM me and they're like
hey can I send you some music for me to
use in the videos and I say totally they
do and that's where I get my Vlog music
from I don't know how to make music I
just know what sounds right and my rule
with people who send me the music is
like if it's just a video I post on
YouTube I credit you and I I'll send you
as much attention as I can if it's like
a commercial I can figure out how to get
paid for it I always send them a nice
Cut Is there any other question that's
better for me to end on I have to admit
I was like a little bit timid because I
know that like sometimes if you Google
somebody you might see some stuff that's
unsavory but I would say you guys did an
excellent job of protecting me from that
so now that I've seen behind the scenes
I just appreciate the discretion
appreciate you guys looking out for me
thank you for having me and I look
forward to doing the sequel to this
where we're going to have to come up
with like 60 more questions about stuff
I don't think we can talk about running
anymore all right thanks for having
me it's I can't look you